[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
JOHN DOLHUN: Good
afternoon, everyone.
So I'm going to start off today
with a small demonstration.
And I wonder if
somebody could tell me
what are the states of matter?
Yeah?
Aisha?
AUDIENCE: Solid, liquid,
gas, and then [INAUDIBLE]..
JOHN DOLHUN: Solid,
liquid, gas, and plasma.
Good.
OK.
So the plasma is one that we
don't oftentimes talk about.
And that's what
we're going to be
talking about in this lecture.
So what we're going to
do-- a plasma basically
is a group of ionized
gas molecules.
The sun and the
stars are plasma.
This is a plasma globe,
which on a small scale
you're not actually going to be
able to see the plasma inside
because it's not hot enough.
But we'll be able to see the
colors from the emissions.
So ionization is when an
electron hits a gas particle,
kicks an electron off,
and produces a gas ion.
That's ionization.
That's what's happening
on the Sun and the stars.
I mean, you've got this sea
of ions that's molting hot.
And then emission happens when
the gas ion grabs its electron
back.
And what it does is
then it gives off light.
And that's what we're
going to see here.
So I've got two
plasmas actually.
I've got the plasma globe.
And I've also got a
fluorescent light bulb,
which is also a plasma.
And I need a volunteer--
someone who wants to be a
conductor between the two
plasmas.
Someone who's not--
Alex, come on down.
All right.
So Alex, you can stand
right in the front
actually, kind of over here.
So we're going to
start by just shining
120 volts through this globe.
That's 120 volts going through.
And what I'm going to be
doing is putting 70,000 volts
through this.
And then we're going to--
Alex is going to
be the conductor.
So we're going to put the
70,000 volts through Alex.
They'll crawl along his skin--
the surface of his skin.
And he's going to hold
the fluorescent light
bulb in his other hand.
And I don't know.
Hopefully he'll be
able to light it.
I mean in that fluorescent
light bulb, it's plasma.
There's mercury.
You have to ionize
the mercury first.
It gives off UV radiation,
grabs its electron back,
and then it shines
that invisible UV
on the phosphorescent
coating of the bulb.
And we see the white
light given off.
So we'll try this out.
Can someone shut the
lights off there?
Just turn those lights off?
Yeah.
I think so.
Just hold that in.
That's perfect.
So before we start Alex, I
think we're going to have you--
let's see if we get
this thing going here.
You want to just bring
your hand up toward that?
Yeah.
OK.
All right.
Put this pair of
goggles on just in case.
OK.
Mainly for the fluorescent bulb.
Now what's going
to happen now is
I'm going to have you
hold your hand there.
And don't take it off.
You're not going to get shocked.
AUDIENCE: OK.
JOHN DOLHUN: And I'm
going to have you
hold this in your other hand.
Now put your hand there.
Good.
Now here we go.
Ready?
Wow.
AUDIENCE: Really cool.
JOHN DOLHUN: All right.
You feel a little
warmth on your hand?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JOHN DOLHUN: Not too hot?
AUDIENCE: Not too hot.
No.
JOHN DOLHUN: 70,000
volts going through him
along the surface of his
skin coming out the hand
and ionizing the mercury in
a fluorescent light bulb.
So that's pretty good.
Thank you very much, Alex.
You're very brave.
Yeah give him a hand.
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
So you saw two plasmas there.
And the plasma we're going
to talk about today--
and here we'll bring the
lights back up there.
Oh, there we go.
He's got it.
We've got our own
technician here.
So excellent.
So we've reached the final
lecture in this series.
We're going to be talking
about inductively coupled
plasma mass spectrometry.
And this is a
lecture where you'll
be able to impress
yourself and your friends
because there's only two
of these machines at MIT.
And it's a very
rare opportunity.
We're actually introducing
this machine in 5.310.
You're going to be the first
ones that have an opportunity
to use this machine.
So we're going to answer a
series of questions here.
What is ICP-MS?
What can be detected with it?
What are the main components?
How it works.
And some of the challenges
we're going to face in using it.
And then we'll talk a little
bit about the MIT Experiment.
And we'll spend
the last 10 minutes
or so talking about
mercury analysis.
So inductively coupled
plasma mass spectrometry.
There are two things
that separate this
from all other
forms of mass spec.
And they are high
temperature and high energy.
And it's a combination
of those two things
that allows the
sample to decompose.
It undergoes atomization
and then ionization.
So what you can actually
detect with this
is pretty much most of the
elements in the periodic table
at the part per trillion level.
That's mind boggling-- at
the part per trillion level.
And what this machine does
is it scans from 5 lithium--
this is the mass scale up
to 260, which is uranium.
Now that's another big
difference between this
and the other forms
of mass spectrometry.
Because the other forms--
we have molecular
weights that are
in the hundreds of thousands
for these nucleic acids,
these carbohydrates,
the proteins
that we're trying to study.
And from regular mass spec,
which is a much lower energy,
much lower ionization, we're
looking for molecular weight
information about
these biomolecules
and some fragmentation
information.
So we're primarily concerned
about carbon, hydrogen, oxygen,
nitrogen, phosphorus,
and sulfur.
Those are pretty much the six
elements regular mass spec
would be concerned with.
With this machine we're rapidly
scanning the whole range
of all these elements
and the mass range--
the top mass range is
260 for this machine.
So that's the big difference.
Now, what are the
main components?
So what we've got is we've
got our sample introduction.
And the sample is
going to be a liquid.
So it's a liquid that
enters the sample intro.
And that liquid is
converted to an aerosol.
And the aerosol gets shot
into a plasma ion source.
And in that ion
source, that's where
your ionization takes place.
Sample is going to be dried
out, decomposed, atomized,
and the elements are
going to be ionized.
And then we've got an ion lens,
which focuses that ion beam.
So this focuses the ion beam.
We also have a
collision reaction cell,
where we actually
introduce helium.
And the helium bombards
our ions and gets rid
of the interferences,
like the polyatomic ions
we're going to talk about.
So this removes interferences.
And then the monatomic
ions that are
left to enter this
quadrupole mass
analyzer, which is four rods--
the ions travel down
the center of those rods
and they're sorted by their
mass to charge ratios.
The ions are then
counted at the detector.
And we've got-- the
detector actually
records the counts per second
of every ion hitting it.
And these counts can be
like hundreds of thousands
of counts for each
ion every second.
So counts per second recorded.
And interestingly, the detector
takes those counts per second
and then it goes and looks
at our calibration standards.
And it associates
those counts per second
with our concentrations in
our calibration standards.
And then you've got
concentration for your samples.
So the counts per
second then head
into our data system and the
software analyzes all this
and produces us some data.
Let's take a look
and see how it works.
So here's our sample--
a liquid sample.
And we've got a little
peristaltic pump
that pumps the liquid up to
this thing called the nebulizer.
The nebulizer is going to
convert it into an aerosol.
But coming in here, notice
there's a dilution gas.
The dilution gas is argon.
And argon actually dilutes
our sample right at that point
before it enters
this spray chamber.
Once the aerosol gets in
here, there's a make up gas--
also argon-- that
pushes the droplets down
to the bottom of the tube.
Once they're down
here, they have
to make two right turns to
end up outside the ion source.
And those two right
hand turns cause
the larger droplets to be pumped
out and fall by the wayside.
So the most sample
that is actually
going to enter this ion
source is only about 2%
of our original sample.
We've gotten rid of the rest.
Now once it goes
into this ion source,
there are three
concentric glass tubes.
So the ions will go into
the center tube here.
And look at these
gases coming in here.
Plasma gas and
auxiliary gas-- they're
coming in at right angles.
And both of those
gases are argon.
So the gas comes
in at right angles
and it forms like a mini
tornado inside of this tube.
It's like a hurricane
going on in there.
And that cyclonic motion picks
up the sample into a vortex.
And what goes into a
vortex stays in a vortex.
Right?
So you've got your
sample trapped up
in this vortex moving
through this tube.
And then there's an electrode
sending electrons out.
And look at this.
We've got this Rf coil
wrapped around the glass tube.
That's producing about
1,500 watts of power.
It's like 27.1 megahertz.
And look at my hand.
The old right hand
rule goes into play.
Remember this.
What are my fingers doing?
What are we making in that tub?
Roberto?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JOHN DOLHUN: Yeah, an
electromagnetic field.
And that electromagnetic field
is thrashing around in there.
And it's so powerful that it
can rip an electron off argon.
So we've got our argon
hitting that energy.
There's your high energy.
And you've got argon
ions plus electrons.
And those argon
ions and electrons
are just smashing around,
twirling around in there.
And the collisions from that,
the kinetic energy that's
given off--
that's your plasma.
So that's all happening
inside of that tube.
Let's take a bigger view of it.
This is a blown up view
of what's happening here.
So here is your aerosol sample
going down the center tube.
What happens to the
sample is it's actually--
the liquid is dried out
to a solid in that tube.
And then that
solid is vaporized.
It's atomized, decomposed,
and then ionized.
The temperatures in here--
they can get up to 8,000 kelvin.
I mean, you're talking like the
temperature of the sun is what?
6,000-- a little
under 6,000 Kelvin?
So the temperatures
are very hot.
And you can see this plasma
when the machine is on.
You'll see the glow of this
white hot plasma that's
actually formed in there.
So what you've got is
your ions coming out.
Your plus charged ions
will come out here.
And what's going to happen is
they will then enter the ion
lens, which I'll show you.
So what I've done here is I've
actually opened up our machine.
And this is the ion source.
That's where the
plasma is generated.
It's a glass tube.
And you can see
the Rf coil there.
And right behind it, you can't
see, is this sample cone.
So what I did is push a button
here and moved this back
to reveal the sample cone.
Now think about this.
Inside of this box you've got
like 6,000 Kelvin going on
in there.
Outside is room temperature.
It's like putting the
Earth a couple of miles
away from the sun.
That's what you're doing here.
And what this cone is,
it's made of copper.
And it's got a nickel center
with the little hole in it.
And what happens is there's
a grounding system here.
So the electrons coming
out of this torch box,
coming out at the speed
of light, go to ground.
The positive
charges-- the ions--
cannot go to ground.
So they build up on this cone.
And here you've got a cone
with all these positive ions
building up with
a tiny hole in it.
It's a no brainer.
They get pushed through.
And so on the other
side of this box
is the high vacuum low pressure
area of the mass spectrometer.
So we've got here-- we've
got this high temperature,
high pressure.
We've got room temperature and
then we've got low pressure.
Three areas of this
mass spectrometer.
So the ions going
through this, that's
the best definition of
an ion lens you can have.
And I unscrewed this so
you could see inside.
There's a skimmer cone--
another cone-- before you
get into the high vacuum area.
So now let's talk a moment
about the challenges
with this system.
There are some challenges.
Nothing is easy.
Right?
In this world everything
can be challenging.
So it turns out
that there are a lot
of isotopes of
different elements
that have the same mass.
They overlap.
These are isobaric overlap--
calcium 40 and argon 40, iron
58, nickel 58, indium 115,
and tin 115.
Isobaric overlaps are
pretty easy to take
care of because we can
choose an interference
free isotope of the element.
That means that every
one of these elements
has at least one isotope
that doesn't overlap.
So with the ICP-MS we can
key in on that isotope
and measure just that
isotope and we're good.
The only problem is indium
115 doesn't have any isotopes.
They all overlap with something.
So what we have to do
is type an equation
into the mass spectrometer
to take care of that.
And the main
interference is tin 115.
So the equation
is pretty simple.
We take the counts per second
of indium that we want to find.
And we take the
counts per second
of everything, which is the
indium 115 plus the tin 115.
That's the total
counts we're seeing.
And then we subtract the counts
per second of the interferent.
And the way we get that
is we multiply this
by an isotope ratio.
We multiply it by the abundance
of the interferent divided
by the abundance of an isotope
of tin that does not interfere,
which would be tin 118.
So we can take those two
abundances, get a ratio there.
Multiply that times the
total counts and end up
getting our counts
for indium 115.
And all this is done
by the software.
There's one other
equation I have to put
in this mass spectrometer.
It's for lead because
lead 206, 207, and 208--
any time you dig up lead
anywhere on the Earth
basically, the isotope ratios
will always be different
because of all the radioactive
decay that's going on
from when the Earth was formed.
And so we put this in.
And we add all the isotopes
of lead up to the 208
and we get a total
and that that's good.
That's how we do it.
Then we have these
polyatomic ions.
In the plasma you've
got argon and oxygen.
So they can combine
with each other
to form these polyatomics, which
interfere with other elements.
They overlap directly.
Argon, argon, which would
be argon 40 and argon 38
overlaps with selenium.
And then if we add our
matrix like our acids--
hydrochloric acid you're
putting chlorine in.
Sulfuric you're putting sulfur.
Nitric you're putting nitrogen.
So you can have a
whole slew of these.
The two most challenging
ones are selenium 78
and arsenic 75 because those
two elements give the weakest
signal of all the
elements for ICP-MS.
The only ionize about 30%.
So we've got to get rid
of these polyatomics.
Another thing that
can happen is you can
have doubly charged ions form.
Cerium is an element
in our tuning solution.
Cerium has a molecular
weight of 140.
If it's doubly charged,
you divide that by 2
and you get 70.
So a doubly charged cerium
would interfere with gallium.
So somehow, we've got to
take these into account.
And there's a whole
table of them.
Look at this.
I'm giving you this so
you don't have to search
for these in the dark.
This is everything right here.
Everything that I wrote
up there is included here.
And typically, most
of these interferences
come below mass 82.
So how are we going
to deal with these?
We've got to figure out
a way to deal with them.
And in comes the
collision reaction cell.
So just to put this
back in perspective--
here's our nebulizer
and our tube--
our torch.
And then this is the
high vacuum low pressure
area of the mass spectrometer.
So we've got a collision
reaction cell here
that we put helium in.
And we fill it with helium and
the helium starts colliding
with the ions--
both the polyatomics
and the monatomics.
And those collisions give
off the same kinetic energy,
whether it's a plus
1 ion or polyatomic.
However, think about this.
Polyatomics are
bigger so they start
colliding more frequently
with the helium
so they give off
more kinetic energy.
So there's a positive
discrimination voltage--
a kinetic energy
of discrimination
that prevents the
polyatomics from going out
of that octupole, that
collision reaction cell.
This is amazing.
I mean, 15 years
ago or something
they didn't have this.
They had to put equations
in for everything.
Now at least there's a way to
get rid of the polyatomics.
So what goes through are
the monatomic ions down
this quadrupole mass
filter toward the detector.
This is the detector.
It's a pretty fancy detector.
It's got these dynodes, which
are electrodes in vacuum that
produce electrons.
They multiply electrons.
This thing has 26 dynodes
connected together.
So when the ion hits, it
produces a couple electrons.
Those electrons hit
the next dynode.
They get multiplied
exponentially
and then it continues.
And then finally, you get
down here to the last dynode
and that's called
your pulse signal.
And that's where you could have
a million counts or something.
And once that signal
becomes saturated
then the machine says to
itself well, wait a minute.
I have to pull back.
So it goes back a few dynodes,
picks up the analog signal,
and then the software multiplies
that by some pulse analog ratio
to make it look like a pulse.
It's quite complex.
But you can actually-- when
it's graphing your elements,
if a point goes
on the graph, you
can tell whether it's
a pulse or analog point
and if it's been corrected.
So this is pretty
much the detector.
Let's see what
else we have here.
So what are we going
to detect in this lab?
So we're actually going to be
looking at these 29 elements.
We picked 29 elements
that we're going
to be scanning and monitoring
during our river lab.
What we did is we
actually got standards
that contained these 29 elements
so we could make up calibration
standards for you for this lab.
We also have a set of
internal standards, which
are four elements that are
not part of the 29 elements
that we're looking at.
And the internal standards
are there to actually--
they're pumping
through the machine
constantly with every sample,
with every calibration
standard, with your blanks,
and they're telling us
about the drift of the machine.
We can look at this and see,
oh, things look pretty good.
They're hugging
together very nicely.
This run here is
about a five hour run.
And so if those internal
standards are staying together,
we know the machine
is doing well.
But if something happens
to the internal standards,
then we see we might
have a problem.
So we can actually go in and try
to figure out what's going on.
Along with this, we also have
quality control standards.
Here's your 29 elements again.
But we bought these
from a different company
than our calibration standards.
And each one of the
elements in this mix
has a defined concentration.
So this mix comes from the
National Institute of Standards
in Gaithersburg, Maryland.
And we'll be running one
of these with your samples.
So you'll be able
to look at this
and say, oh, these
look pretty good.
We're very close to
the ranges we want.
That means things
are working well.
Your results are really
going to mean something
when we have all these controls
and all our calibration
standards and quality
control standards.
So a little bit of
EPA terminology--
when you get your report,
which will be a PDF file,
you'll see various things
like calibration blank.
What this is just
reagent water that's
acidified the same way as
our calibration standards.
And we run that blank before we
run the calibration standards.
And then we'll run a series of
maybe 10 calibration standards,
do another blank, then we'll run
our quality control standard.
And we'll also be running
something called a laboratory
reagent blank where
one of the TAs
will actually take water
to the river Milli-Q water.
And open it up and just let
it breathe the air there.
And then bring it
back to the lab.
And then they're going
to filter that water
the same way you're filtering
your real river samples.
And then they're going
to acidify it exactly
like you're acidifying
your river samples.
And so we're going to have a
blank called the laboratory
reagent blank that will
tell us, hey, there
may have been something
in the funnel we're using
or something in one of those
new filtering membrane disks
that got into this
sample and it's also
going to be in your sample.
So that's another
quality control.
And then we've got-- we're
going to run 10 samples.
And then we run a CCB, which is
a continuing calibration blank.
It's another blank just to
make sure everything's OK.
And then we run a CCV, which
is a continuing calibration
verification, which ends
up being one of our--
we pick one of our
calibration standards.
Usually the midpoint standard.
And we stick it in there just to
make sure things are still OK.
Then we'll run another
10 samples, another CCB,
and a CCV.
So that's what those terms mean.
When you see these
you're not overwhelmed.
You'll kind of understand
what these terms are.
This is from the EPA method
that we're actually using.
The protocol is very detailed.
And the TAs are going to go
over this with you in the lab.
They'll pull out
the tubes, they'll
pull out the filtration system.
They'll show you how to
connect it to the vacuum,
show you what kind of
bottles to take to the river
and collect this from.
So they'll be going
through all of this.
Now we have to
talk about mercury.
There's a lot of mercury
up there in the atmosphere.
Who knows where all this
mercury's coming from?
Where does all the
elemental mercury
in the atmosphere come--
Brian?
AUDIENCE: Coal.
JOHN DOLHUN: Coal is a big one.
Yeah.
That's a man made source
of some of the mercury.
Yeah.
What else?
I mean, look at the mercury.
Look at the elemental mercury
floating around up there.
Where else could it come from
besides our energy source?
Yes, Autumn?
AUDIENCE: Maybe if there's
like a forest fire.
JOHN DOLHUN: Forest fires.
That would definitely be
a big source of mercury.
Yeah.
Anything else?
Yeah, Ryan?
AUDIENCE: I mean, it's
definitely in the water,
but like for [INAUDIBLE]
JOHN DOLHUN: Yeah.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
It's in the dirt and
rocks and evaporating out.
Yeah.
I mean, another big source would
be volcanoes-- natural source.
Yeah.
So probably about 2/3 of it
comes from our fossil fuels
and a third of it comes
from natural sources.
But once it gets
up there, once it's
in the atmosphere, this
elemental mercury--
there are plenty of things
up there that can oxidize it.
There's ozone up there.
There's hydroxide radicals.
There's chlorine and
bromine in the troposphere.
So this elemental mercury
gets oxidized to mercury 2.
And then it rains outside.
Right?
Where do you think that
mercury 2 goes when it rains?
It's coming down on us.
Right?
It's going into the water.
And once it gets
in the water there
are a couple of things
that can happen.
It can have it can
be photoreduced here.
And you can form the
elemental mercury back.
And some of that can vaporize
back up into the atmosphere.
Or the mercury too
can get down here
into the depths of the water.
And this is where the
bad things happen.
This is where the nasty
methyl mercury is formed.
So once it gets down here we
know that mercury loves sulfur.
So it can attach
itself to this--
there's plenty of hydrogen
sulfide in the water.
It can attach itself to
the sulfur and form mercury
sulfide.
And this is a neutral molecule.
Being a neutral
molecule it can go right
through a bacterial cell wall.
And once it's inside
of a bacteria--
there are some
bacteria down there
that produce methyl mercury.
Nobody knows how it's done.
They know that the
mercury sulfide goes in,
but they don't know
the exact mechanism.
The other thing
that's not known is
that there are some
fish out there that
have millions of parts of
mercury in their systems,
much more than the
surrounding water.
So there's got to be some
other sources of this methyl
mercury down there somewhere
that they haven't really
pinpointed.
So once we get this
methyl mercury--
I just told you it loves sulfur.
Right?
So you get this
stuff in the body--
this organic form of mercury.
It's going to go for your
cysteine amino acids.
And it forms a covalent
bond to the sulfur.
So you've got this carboxy ethyl
sulfonyl methyl mercury here.
Now you think about the
cysteine amino acids--
we've got them in our proteins.
So this methyl mercury,
once it's inside of ourself
it can go for all the proteins
and infiltrate covalently bond
and hook up to all
these cysteines.
Once we get methyl
mercury inside of us
from eating the fish,
it's like bioaccumulation.
It's down the biofood chain.
It starts with the plankton,
then the small fish,
and the bigger fish.
Then we get it.
This stuff-- 90% of
the methyl mercury
can actually come out of our
gut, get into our bloodstream,
and it can pass through
the blood brain barrier.
So it gets into our
central nervous system
and can wreak havoc.
It can also go
through the placenta.
And the fetus is just in there.
I mean, it's just developing.
And once methyl
mercury gets in there
you can have total decontrol
of the whole thing.
Everything can fall
apart for that.
So this is really bad stuff.
Now what we're going
to be doing in this lab
is actually we're going
to be detecting this
and we're going to be using our
new DMA 80 atomic absorption
spectrometer.
And this spectrometer
operates under three things.
There are three
things happening here.
So we've got
thermal degradation.
You've got amalgamation.
And we've got atomic absorption.
This spectrometer has two
detectors and three cells.
It's called a tri cell.
So on the nanogram scale
and the PPB scale--
one of the cells will
detect from about 0.01
to 10 nanograms, which
is like 0.1 to 100 PPB.
The next cell will detect
between 10 and 20 nanograms,
which is 100 to 200 PPB.
And the third cell will
pick up the last range
from 20 to 1,500 nanograms,
which is 200 to 15,000 PPB.
The detection limit
of this machine
is to the thousandths
of a nanogram.
So detects text down
to 0.001 nanogram.
Can actually-- you're talking
almost a part per trillion
there with this machine.
So it's really a
fantastic machine.
So let's actually see
how this machine works.
So this is a little
schematic of this machine.
And I did this on ChemDraw.
So ChemDraw is amazing.
It is just-- you can do just
about anything with ChemDraw.
So we've got a tank
of oxygen that you'll
see it sitting in the lab.
And then we have this
autosampler, which
is a 40 position autosampler.
And so we'll be massing
out our fish, putting it
into the autosampler.
And then this little
pneumatic arm comes out,
grabs your sample out of
the autosampler, and inserts
it into this drying
decomposition oven.
And the drying
decomposition oven
will heat the sample up to
about 650 degrees or so.
And it combusts everything.
And all of the combustion
products of your sample
are carried by the
stream of oxygen gas
into this catalyst tube furnace.
Everything goes in
the catalyst tube.
And that catalyst tube gets
heated up to about 500 degrees.
And it pulls everything out--
literally all the NOxes, SOxes,
everything you can think of.
Not only that, it converts
every mercury species,
including methyl mercury down
to the elemental mercury.
The only thing that comes
out of that catalyst tube
is the elemental mercury.
I know it's hard
to believe that,
but everything else stays
in the catalyst tube.
So the elemental
mercury comes out
and goes into a
gold amalgamator.
And all it is a glass tube
filled with tiny gold beads.
And the mercury comes
out, goes in there,
and sticks to those beads.
Then this gold amalgamator is
flash heated up to 900 degrees.
And bam!
You release the mercury vapor.
And the vapor goes into
the atomic absorption
part of the instrument that
has our tri cells-- our three
cells.
So we've got two mercury lamps.
They're shining light
on the samples--
like 254 nanometers.
And the light goes in,
shines on the sample,
and then we record the height
of the peak in the absorbance
that's going on.
And we figure out
our concentrations
of the mercury in our samples.
So this is a great machine.
Do you guys have any
questions about this machine
or the ICP-MS?
There's no sample prep for
this machine, which is amazing.
We can do solids,
liquids, or gases.
And you can actually
follow your sample through.
There's a system status
that you can turn on
and you can see your
sample traveling
through the various positions
while it's going through.
It's pretty easy.
Just three simple steps.
You cut up your fishy.
Right?
And we'll have several native
fish to the Charles River.
So you'll be able to--
I know.
It's not that bad.
Maida.
Don't pass out on me.
No, it really won't be that bad.
But you'll take your fish,
put a piece on the boat,
and weigh it--
mass it-- and then you type
your mass into the machine,
put it in the autosampler,
and that's pretty much goes.
You're going to do this
on Monday and Tuesday.
You'll do this at the
beginning and then
after that, you'll
make up your standards
for the phosphate lab.
And you'll do the
phosphate testing.
You'll go to the river and
get your bottle of water
for the phosphate.
Any questions?
Yes, Autumn?
AUDIENCE: Is there any research
on how to remove mercury
from other animals or from us?
JOHN DOLHUN: They have--
there are certain
chemicals that you
could get prescribed
that would actually
chelate some of the mercury.
Yeah.
And chelate means
to latch on to it
and try to pull it out
of your bloodstream.
Yeah.
I don't know anyone that's
actually been mercury poisoned
to that extent.
But I know there are chemicals
that you can take that will
help mitigate some of that.
Yeah.
Other questions?
So when we're doing the
ICP-MS next Wednesday
and Thursday, we'll
have you-- you
can come in and
take a peek at it.
You can look at the plasma.
You'll see it lit up.
And you can see the
signal on the screen--
how we're looking at
the signal and we're
getting it all ready
for your samples.
I'll also have an associate
here from Agilent--
a PhD chemist who is
actually going to-- he
wanted to come
just for this lab.
So I told him to come on.
So he'll be a great source to
talk to when you're coming in.
Yeah.
So I'm kind of excited
that you're the first group
to use this machine.
And I think it'll
be exciting for you.
I mean, the Charles
River is probably
the cleanest river in America.
Yes.
Believe it or not.
But you know, there's still--
it has to be monitored.
We still find problems
from time to time.
So we will see
you up in the lab.
And next week, Dr.
Sarah Hewett will
start a new series of lectures.